and they're still we're still feeling
the profound loss for the pandemic as I
mentioned we have over 100 people dead
true it was over 100 Mr President
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
happy Tuesday everybody
yeah keep it going don't stop all right
that's enough that's enough so the last
time I looked America was supposed to be
a meritocracy ever since the pilgrims
landed wherever we knew there'd be no
Welcome Wagon you had to work to eat and
it wasn't like you could go running to
HR if you weren't happy and had
complaints and for that reason it was
generally the best person who always got
the job
well most of the time
of course there were injustices but
we've always been a nation of achievers
I mean look at me where else can a guy
go from a humble Chippendales dancer
to the king of late nights yeah
[Applause]
on sale today wherever Priceless works
of art are sold you probably go to
Amazon and get it right now but things
have changed meritocracy is now
mediocrity and I'm not just saying that
because Jesse Waters has an 8pm show
why him why him he even Wonders that
himself today wherever Dems have power
the Box you check trumps the work you've
done let's start with National Defense
where they promote generals like they're
casting a commercial after our hideous
Afghanistan pull out if you dare to
suggest that Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin be fired you had to be racist
although the dude could lose a war to
menudo and keep adding to his pension
of course top General Mark milley and
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
should have been fired too and there is
white as Elizabeth Warren
Jake Sullivan looks like an albino
making a snow angel
and Millie looks like a mayonnaise
sandwich
oh
but the White House has been Relentless
in signaling its obedience to diversity
with Millie soon to retire as chairman
of the Joint Chiefs Biden's pushing
General Charles Brown Jr now this is
someone who prioritized Dei initiatives
and once said flat out quote I hire for
diversity and this anti-meritocracy is
all over take the Texas border millions
of illegals already have Texas is so
desperate they're installing a blow up
pontoons in an attempt to harden their
defenses yep the nation that defeated
Hitler and invented the nuclear bomb is
now defending itself with balloons which
will only work until someone brings a
safety pin
DHS secretary Alejandro mayorkas in
charge of our border security had this
to say
no we didn't forget the clip he had
nothing significant to say
he never does
yeah
but you know he only talks if it's to
lie about his own Personnel using whips
to hurt illegals which never happened so
was this the best we could do meanwhile
our nation still produces 2 000 tons of
nuclear waste every year and that's just
from the sewers attached to the Views
bathrooms
I know it's disgusting
so of course the White House's main
Criterion for handling it was someone
who checked a box that few even knew
existed Sam Brinton a non-binary baldy
was named assistant Secretary of spent
fuel disposition handling the nation's
nuclear waste disposal
but after looking at him the only part
of that title that fits is secretary
[Laughter]
although I wouldn't trust him to get his
boss coffee he'd only steal the mug he's
been arrested for stealing luggage from
airports a couple times who did that
background check this guy
hahaha
Pete bootage is the former mayor of
South Bend Indiana in Indiana is that a
state Indiana Indiana
population a hundred and three thousand
but he's gay so why not make him
Secretary of Transportation where he
quickly took two months paternity leave
off and right around when our supply
chain began to stack up like the line at
the pharmacy after pride month
what I ended up having to treat my
monkey pox with green tea and wet
newspapers
meanwhile our airline industry currently
runs about as smoothly as Joy behar's
colon after a White Castle Run
but complain you ate the Gaze and does
anyone really think Rachel Levine the
trans head of Health and Human Services
is a good choice who just said kids
going through the wrong puberty should
receive hormone injections that sounds
like child abuse to me but kudos for
pairing the right lipstick with a five
o'clock shadow
the scrap is reaching the local level
too there's New Hampshire State Rep
Stacy Marie Lawton
what a looker
trans activists now despite a criminal
pass she was endorsed by Beto O'Rourke
and fart master swalwell and you know
why
and yet she or it recently got busted
for child porn you can read up on it but
you're gonna wish you hadn't and then
there's this higher
the president has done everything that
he can president is doing everything
that he can he is doing everything that
he can we will do everything that we can
I don't have a policy update on that but
I know to tell you now as I've been
saying we are doing everything that we
can possibly we're going to continue to
do everything that we can I don't have
anything to preview for you I keep
waiting for her to say press one for
more options I know right
but she seems articulate compared to
this crackpot
[Laughter]
see I wish
I wish but this combination of Xanax and
a banana peel could end up running the
place now the left will turn the story
around and say oh look whites are
worried about losing out on jobs no I
don't want to be in government I barely
want to work I just don't want to die
because the person they choose is so
awful you want the guy operating on your
kid to be excellent or diverse it's the
only question that really matters hell
maybe the next diversity hire should be
the pilot flying Air Force One I wonder
how that will go over literally
what
what welcome
[Applause]
welcome
she always plays out kick host Charlie
Arnold
you may recognize him from the cover of
lonely Bachelor magazine comedian Joe
DeVito
he's filled my shoes on red eye with
cement Fox News contributor Tom Saloon
and she's like the month of August hot
and has killed many Floridians Fox News
contributor Kat Tiff
so Tom I've noticed that you you tick
off no boxes at all yeah yeah you were
as Bland as like uh I don't know he's
getting no jobs yeah you're getting no
jobs well maybe I'd be a domestic
extremist in this Administration you
gotta you know you gotta have a couple
of them right uh this guy the the the
the head of the diversity he said that
diversity is he purposefully likes
diversity and then he wants to say that
it's because you get different
perspectives right which is kind of true
yeah I mean if you think isn't it a
little racist though yeah that's true
yeah so but since it's false then well
although maybe in a company you could
excuse that but in the military isn't
that the one place you don't want
differing perspectives yes it's like
yeah drop give me 20. unless you have a
different perspective on exercise what's
your way of getting they do though have
a different perspective on extra size
though yeah the physical fitness
standards they have gone away
because of the diversity no because of
hormone treatments you're getting
hormone treatments now and they're
giving you negative effects you no
longer have to meet the standards you
didn't hear about that yeah you get to
take care you get to get take you get to
take like nine months off the training
plus everybody's so fat they got to
lower the standards too so you may not
have people have like people who are
obese have a different Viewpoint Tom
yeah but you didn't know that because
you're uh you're photophobic yeah
exactly well I I only read this one
story Greg yeah I expect you to read
more than just the stories I ask you I
expect you to read everything
Charlie you come from the World of
Sports I'm familiar with it as you know
I'm an excellent athlete I turned down
many offers to play professional
baseball football and basketball but I
decided to choose a career in TV because
I wanted to serve our country yeah
do you think this kind of diversity
would ever go well in sports should we
apply to the NBA perhaps uh I don't know
that it would go so well you know like
employing short people how dare you I
don't know right go over so well I think
that there's you know there's certain
conditions that you must meet to play in
professional sports leagues and I think
that you know if they want to keep
winning they probably will keep them
going the same way and unlike our
military though like we're assembling it
now like a bad Broadway cast yes it
seems like and you know I wish Russia
China and Iran did the same things
otherwise the social experiment I'd I'd
be totally in for yeah but
qualifications don't matter anymore it
does it's like our military commercials
look like an ad for rent yeah
the Off-Broadway the Off-Broadway broad
Ray rent
Joe
um you're uh just like Tom you uh you
you don't take many boxes except maybe
shut in potential serial killer
um
underwear stealer
I settled that case with the laundromat
years ago
well despite the ramp in short phobia
yes from over here I agree with them
that I think they should search for the
most qualified people with diversity as
a factor and from the people they've
selected they need to keep searching
because they're not giving us I mean
this this uh General Brown saying that
diversity is the first thing he looks
for that's not you want competence these
are people with flying around in planes
and shooting missiles I mean look at the
people look at the Chinese Army not
particularly diverse no not Asian guys
from what I saw
so yeah it's it's absurd to say that and
I don't like it because you look at
someone like Kareen Jean-Pierre and
she's just not good at her job right but
you can't criticize her because she's
she's stacked up well she's a woman
she's gay she's black and the more
things I stack up I'm waiting for to
come in with an eye patch and a crutch
and say well she's a disabled pirate you
can't say anything do it yeah it's the
same thing they do with Greta Greta
thunderberg they said you can't how dare
you criticize her she's a child it's
like why are we taking climate advice
from her exactly exactly now and also
she has a disorder right you can see on
the Spectrum yeah exactly so uh cat you
know um this fellow over here with the
beard creepy dude don't make eye contact
uh he's right the search is is naturally
going to be shallow because there aren't
going to be a lot of people in that area
so they're going to take the first or
second person because there might only
be two
I disagree I think that there's a lot of
gay men out there that are very
organized yes but like who would do a
lot better than people to judge like yes
that's true that's true they run things
yeah yeah I also feel bad because you're
so busy and you shouldn't have spent all
that time doing that monologue because I
feel like it's pretty clear that you
have a different view on diversity just
based on the panel you've assembled to
discuss it like
you could just wait for that joke you
couldn't know you I could guess that
joke coming before I even ask okay well
then maybe you should have made it you
could have you could have made it I said
here's the here's the news story and
with me to discuss four other white
people yeah it's because you made that
joke already I think that
diversity provides a lot of it's
important to have different perspectives
and there's certain perspectives that
for example a woman would have because
she's a woman but the fact that it ends
there you don't need to look at anything
else or that it's even the most
important thing it's kind of scary
because of a lot of the things you
mentioned sure but also because you have
to have different ideas too like I am a
woman Charlie's a woman but she knows
for example more about football than the
fact that touchdowns are good and that
the quarterback's the one who throws it
there you go all right you're on to
something though it's a lot further than
I was two years ago
all righty hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else